comme vous pouvez le voir cette église
derrière moi a été durement touché lors
des combats c'était en 2014 même début
2015 en effet l'aéroport se trouve à
seulement quelques kilomètres d'ici
l'aéroport qui a été le sujet d'une
grande bataille est derrière moi la
nouvelle église qui a été construite
depuis peu mais qui a déjà été la cible
de tirs c'est justement ce manque de
temps sanguin gauche lui
ici en 2014 2015 ont eu lieu
d'importants combats voilà pourquoi
cette église est ce monastère sont
restés ainsi ils ont brûlé vous voyez
combien de fois ils ont été touchés sur
les murs on peux tu imaginer ce qui
s'est passé ici si on se promène dans le
cimetière on voit des pierres tombales
détruites
beaucoup de choses ont été brisées cet
endroit est unique parce que d'un côté
il y à une guerre en cours aidé en même
temps personne n'a baissé les bras la
vie continue et la spiritualité qui est
signé chez les peuples slaves rhône est
ici
gorge des nausées
même si la religion et l'accès aux lieux
de culte sont importants pour la
population du dombass l'emploi est une
préoccupation majeure avec 850 employés
cette usine de fabrication de
réfrigérateurs a le mérite de n'avoir
jamais stoppé son activité même au plus
fort du conflit en 2014 et même si elle
ne tourne qu'à 30% de sa capacité
la direction veut croire à des
lendemains meilleurs
les perspectives c'est l'ouverture de
nouveaux marchés de vente ce qui
permettrait d'utiliser 100 % des
capacités de production d' employer
davantage de personnel et produire 2000
réfrigérateur par jour
le donbass qui était à l'époque le coeur
industriel de l'urss tente aussi de
remettre en ordre de marche son
industrie lourde c'est le cas du haut
fourneau de cette usine métallurgique
qui emploie pas moins de 4500 personnes
lusine fonctionne depuis longtemps mais
après une pause de deux ans elle a
repris son activité le 20 avril 2021
l'année dernière nous avons mis en
service le haut fourneau numéro un à
présent le numéro deux est prêt pour le
lancement rapporte bonhomme à puce ne
doit que ce soit en reconstruisant des
églises ou bien en tentant de relancer
l'activité économique le dombass tentent
de tourner la page et ainsi aller de
l'avant mais tout ceci reste bien
fragile en raison des vives tensions
avec le voisin est créé 1